thank you
[Music]
do you guys remember when we were
talking about the uh the butt Shapers
those like yeah yeah it went up what do
they look like the video went up video
did go I got a couple of my own yeah it
went up uh what did you say I said what
do they look like one second oh what no
hey of course Ryan did all right let's
see who wants to try this on wait no for
real we are gonna review the butt shaper
for ourselves he actually bought it
Nick is Gonna Do It show us a before and
after popular model is this one here
that looks too big for me yeah that's
too big for me yeah yeah just charge it
on and then you got it and then you
literally put these two pieces I think
in the ass all right back so yeah I need
to feel this real quick oh [__] can I
feel it and then one of you guys one of
you guys gotta try this butt lifter it's
a butt lifter that's Bart oh wow
is what hey just make it work that one
actually went over pants or no or under
under and then put your pants on so you
can see if it makes any difference yeah
but you got to show up beautiful yeah
don't take your clothes off in front of
it we're gonna take it's gonna take the
video down remember Nick Nick yeah yeah
yeah yeah show your butt before
I'm already naked dude oh can I see can
I see
don't take it off in front of the camera
because it's gonna take it goes outside
so he goes out in the public so we got
two products one of them is the one that
has like these like padded butt cheeks
and the other one is the lifter and that
one actually grabs your real cheeks and
it lifts them up so we'll see which one
already has ass so that means he's gonna
make it juicier this is this is this is
[Laughter]
hey dude is this gonna get demonetized
super should get demonetized now I don't
think so dang dude
Nick's got cheeks
Nick has a big ass dude hey don't
[__] objectify me dog I gotta touch
it you can't be looking at me like that
you're supposed to put your pants on
over it oh yeah
I am
dying right now I think that's a big ass
dude dude that looks good what's yours I
like the laces [__] I like the Lacy
joint that's the part she likes does it
spread your ass cheeks and lift it I
can't feel it my butt's already too
lifted dude it's not gonna work all
right so put your pants on over and then
we'll compare and see who's looks more
realistic believable we'll have like
different categories yeah I kind of like
I feel them already looks really good
Bart has a juicy butt dude this doesn't
look natural huh yeah yeah well when you
get your pants on put that on can no
it's not gonna fit I have a small waist
hey you know what I think this would be
good for now it's gonna look like Kim
Kardashian on a plane you know what I
mean oh it's like a more cushion yeah
more cushioned put down on it real quick
that's what I can't wait for that's
that's the real test I think is I can't
wait to feel it
yeah does it feel good hell yeah I feel
like a badass [__] because I wear
something like that for snowboarding
yeah what my butt pads yeah but it's
it's like the athletic armor [__] it has
a look
oh
that's extreme
oh my God stop objectifying me bro get
up next to Bart and let's see let's rate
this thing let me sit down that's just
regular butt see this is nice I can sit
on this thing all right Barbara's stick
wow okay we got Barbie
[Laughter]
natural bro it doesn't see that's this
is the problem with the BBL Bart's
actually looks pretty natural if it
don't hurt the thighs yeah it doesn't
let me see it let me feel no Barnes got
lifted dude hey Loki his butt is like
like tighter yeah
what if Bart wears that
oh no oh my God it's gonna be too big
yeah see look it doesn't match the thigh
it's like I think this size would match
Bart's thighs okay he's got it too big
too what's it feel like wearing it I
feel powerful okay there's a lot of
[__] cushion on there I feel like a
female CEO yes you feel more confident I
feel like Jeff Bezos
with a big ass does it does it feel like
are you very aware of it or does it kind
of disappear into the no I feel aware of
it oh okay it's good for the cushion
though oh yeah would you recommend it no
dude no really why
um how's going to the restroom you know
yeah you probably gotta do a lot the
Lacy joint is my favorite part yeah but
girls always they gotta pee that way
anyway they don't pee standing up but
he's telling you look did you know that
yeah but the difference is there's a
difference in the imagery of like
panties being around your ankles versus
like panties and then this giant Lacy
shorts and then two [__] foam things
that you don't want to fall out it kind
of ruins the moment yeah I think that's
more practical
yeah yeah does it feel pretty normal
does it feel like your ass is lifted no
I just feel like compression pants Oh
interesting do you think it's because
guys got more more of a musculy butt
they don't need a lift their saggy asses
it could be yeah there are sad yes but
guys don't worry about that bark lifts
and he also his butt is also legendary
you gotta take that and put on can dude
I'm saying all right now all right can't
switch oh God we can't get a yeast
infection my boy
this is the before right it's not gonna
do anything for me what if you feel
powerful like Jeff Bezos just wait I'll
bring it out bro
[Laughter]
the fact that bar goes outside to change
like that's a fitting room it is in his
mind he's like all right let me not show
this on camera me changing so it doesn't
get demonetized let me go outside and
change and then come back with my pants
off is Joe switching with Bart no yeah I
said I said Joni's where that one of
cans were not oh my God oh my God
[Laughter]
definitely have to
have to
tomorrow it's not gonna fit me but look
how big he's doing don't worry you'll
have you'll have a blast putting that on
dude can with that it's gonna look so
funny dude it feels weird huh I don't
like it yeah but I don't like it just
squat bro because you're worried about
if you're worried about your butt just
squat could you get used to it you could
change your butt like easily it was like
a panty
[Laughter]
[Applause]
God man well I guess they're
non-returnable now I like when we do
props on JK except when it's shocking my
hands I would also love to see the
[__] butt lifter on Steve oh dude you
know now we're getting somewhere we
can't go back the longest back I've ever
seen it can show us his butt while being
shocked
I like the fact that if we're gonna
review a product I think it works on me
but we don't turn yet what do you mean
don't turn yet don't turn wait wait for
Joe wait for Joe I can see it from the
front though boy
[Laughter]
oh I can see it I should just roll your
sweater
turn the bottom into your neck oh look
at that booty Wings we don't want to see
it we don't want to see it yet dude tie
your sweater in the front tight in the
front yeah there we go I could see it
from the front oh [__] oh don't let us
see that dunk wait when do I turn around
just wait uh wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait for Joe wait for Joe stand
right here so you can see it wait for
Joe so we can get the double chip them
out
yeah yeah that's an extra loaded Chabot
right there things along with that Joe's
already got it on that's even starting
he's doing a photo shoot
setting up the tripod oh okay yes it is
I think one of the reviews on this
particular product is that you forget
you're wearing it yeah it's very light
yeah for the size it's like 2XL I think
you got to get the right size for sure
but it could be 2XL for chicks that's
true that's true hey I don't think I
don't think Bart did this right
ha
hahaha
that's why he took something dude Joe's
also one of the most Joe outfit too the
[__] kimonos
all right let's see it let's see that
thing oh yeah
for you guys
can you see that those pants are
seamless dog Joe what do you think of
that
damn fool look at that ass oh let me
pick up the sound
hey stop teasing dog all right which one
do you guys think is better damn I can't
lifter or the pads uh the lifter dude
well we just saw Joe's Butchy the cat
cams ones for sure we didn't get to see
him next but if you're like going to the
bedroom and you start taking [__] off
it's like what the it's like seeing a
chick popper like Dentures out you know
whoa what is that yeah it wasn't rough
bro cause you can't hide it whereas the
one that Joe's wearing that's the sexy
room
intrigued as a sexier reveal but then
when she takes it off her butt sucks
that's not that big of a deal compared
to that yeah the other one's crazy the
other one's crazy so JK you guys uh JK
fans you've heard yourself either way
you should do the squat program that
Bart has we need to do more product
reviews in general product reviews are
great if you guys want to see more
product reviews let us know in the
comments I haven't done the dark night
yet
a season Ender yeah
foreign